fox news alert we have some big news
this morning in the race for the
coronavirus vaccine the drug maker
moderna asking the fda for emergency
approval
of its cova 19 vaccine today here to
react is fox news medical contributor
and author of that book right there
make america healthy again dr nicole
sapphire dr sapphire always good to see
you this is excellent news
can you tell us more about it yep very
exciting news this morning on uh moderna
has
officially been going to file today
their euay from the fda about their
cobin 19 vaccine
they're reporting a 94 efficacy rate
but one of the more important things
that they also said was that it was a
hundred percent
effective in preventing severe illness
similar to the flu shot so some people
may get the flu vaccine
and they still get the flu but it does a
great job in making sure that it is not
the severe effects of the flu
and now it looks like modern is going to
be doing the same thing with covid19 and
that's just another way to keep people
out of the hospital that's great so the
fda is meeting on december 10th to talk
about pfizer will they also be
discussing moderna or will that be a
separate panel
so it's going to be a separate panel
right now the fda is reviewing all the
information that pfizer has submitted
and on december 10th they're going to
convene
and they're going to be doing a
non-binding vote to see if it actually
should get approved from the eua or not
a couple of days before december 10th
we're going to have a good idea if it's
going to be approved or not as their
staff reports going to come out
also one of the most important things
about this process is they're going to
be submitting the documents online
so it's available for public commentary
that is crucial
to get rid of some of this uh some of
the skepticism that's being um
present with the public right now so
it's really important that this process
is transparent which it's going to be
okay i know the cdc is also going to
meet this week to discuss who is going
to get vaccinated first we'll of course
be reporting on that i'm sure we'll have
you back on
to talk about that all right this is dr
celine gallander she is uh biden's
advisor
her she is on his advisory board his
covet advisory board listen to this
nicole and we'll get your reaction on
the other side
we fully expect that in about a week or
two after thanksgiving we will see an
increase in cases first
then about a week or two later you'll
start to see an increase in
hospitalizations
and then another week or two after that
you'll start to see deaths and so
unfortunately that means that many
people who celebrated with family with
friends
over thanksgiving will find themselves
in the hospital
in icus over christmas and new year's dr
sapphire
dr burks even said assume you have it if
you traveled for thanksgiving
so that's right so ainsley you know i've
been saying now for a couple months that
i feel like i should be a translator for
dr fauci and now dr gaunder
because although everything that she is
saying is 100
true we also have to make sure that we
are not pushing the american people
farther away from wanting to adhere to
some of these recommendations
dr fauci said last month that maybe we
should cancel christmas
that is the most ridiculous thing
possible there are many safe ways to be
together for christmas
while i do agree that we had over 9
million americans travel
during the thanksgiving time that will
undoubtedly
result in a rising cases which will
result in a rise in hospitalization
and will also result in a rise of deaths
i think it's important to remind
people the reason that we're doing this
we have uncontrolled spread of the virus
throughout the country right now and
although the far majority of people will
not end up in the hospital and will not
die from this
this is still a very deadly virus we
have a few more months of this
we have pfizer is likely going to
produce 20 million
vaccines for americans by the end of
2020 just give it a few more months
if you did travel over thanksgiving
break i do recommend just assuming that
you have the virus i recommend
assuming everyone has the virus right
now i think i've been saying that to the
spring
do what you can wear mask when you need
to wash your hands if you traveled over
the break
i would consider getting testing right
now if you don't want to self quarantine
for 10 to 14
days and just know there is a big light
at the end of this tunnel
yes christmas is around the corner the
birth of our savior
and then also these vaccines it's great
news thank you so much dr sapphire we
appreciate
having you thank you ainsley